DAN GALPIN: Hello, I'm Dan.
I'm a games developer
advocate here at Google.
KRISTAN UCCELLO: And I'm Krispy,
also a developer advocate
at Google, focused on games.
DAN GALPIN: In
this video, we will
discuss the high-level
aspects of building games
for the big screen.
KRISTAN UCCELLO:
Not that big screen.
TVs, more like this one.
We're going to talk
about what to avoid,
what to strive towards, and how
Google APIs can help support
bringing your apps to
the really big screen.
DAN GALPIN: Much of what
we are about to show
you will apply in the broader
context of the Android
ecosystem surrounding games.
In particular, when you consider
how many Android devices are
able to connect to
large displays using
MiraCast, DisplayPort,
docking hardware,
as well as TVs with
Android built in,
you have at your disposal
a full suite of technology
that can put you in front of an
engaged and growing audience.
There are a lot of mobile
gamers in the world,
and they're looking to expand
their gaming experience
onto the biggest
screen in their home.
We hope that after
watching this,
you will be inspired to make
sure your users get the best
gaming experience
on the big screen.
Android TVs are going
to be coming soon
to a family room near
you, and you'd better
make sure your games
look good on it.
KRISTAN UCCELLO:
With Android TV,
you get to build on your
existing mobile development
experience.
You can now take full
advantage of modern Android,
including NDK support,
to craft your gaming
worlds in unimaginable ways.
It's even possible to
extend the gaming experience
through second-screen
interactions.
DAN GALPIN: TV game
development might
seem to be
overwhelming at first,
considering how many different
aspects are involved.
In practice, though, it's
not very different from what
you were already doing with
your mobile game development.
Your projects can be
managed in the same way.
You just need to factor in a
few additional considerations.
KRISTAN UCCELLO:
Let's start with
my personal favorite--
game controllers.
Many mobile games
use gestures whereby
the user touches the sleek,
glass screen in front of them
to interact with it.
This works fine on a phone,
but not so much for TV screens.
DAN GALPIN: My arms
certainly aren't long enough
to reach across my living room.
KRISTAN UCCELLO: Mine either.
On TV, mobile on-screen
controls become useless.
DAN GALPIN: And even if
my arms were long enough,
touching most TVs would just
result in a messy screen.
KRISTAN UCCELLO:
Yeah, not many people
have touchscreen
TVs, which is why
you need to add
touchscreen required
equal false in your
application manifest.
It's implicit, which means you
need to make the distinction.
DAN GALPIN: Luckily,
every Android TV
will have a controller capable
of producing directional pad
input, thus allowing the
user to interact with the TV.
KRISTAN UCCELLO: Yup.
The Android reference
controller is definitely
a developer's best friend.
It has exactly what you would
expect a game controller
to have-- two analog sticks,
D-pad, B, A, X, Y buttons,
left and right
triggers, left and right
bumpers, Back
button, Home button.
DAN GALPIN: It
can also be paired
with any Bluetooth-capable
Android device, which
means you can play
controller-enabled games
on your phone or tablet as well.
KRISTAN UCCELLO: That's a very
useful thing to do in general.
I'm always a little
surprised and saddened
when I find a game that
would be great to play
with a paired controller, only
to discover it doesn't accept
the controller as valid input.
Even worse, some of these games
have onscreen, simulated game
controllers.
DAN GALPIN: Yeah.
It makes me sad, too, because
the developers have already
done the work of mapping
to the same kinds of input,
but did not include the button
mappings to the hardware.
KRISTAN UCCELLO: With all
the game controller support
that exists with
Android now, I don't
feel there's an excuse for that.
DAN GALPIN: Maybe they
just don't know about it.
KRISTAN UCCELLO: Fair point.
But if you're watching
this, you know about it.
DAN GALPIN: And knowing
is half the battle.
KRISTAN UCCELLO: There's
a few other things
to know too, though.
For instance, Android KitKat
now supports the enumeration
of controllers.
And the game controllers
that support this
will light up accordingly.
DAN GALPIN: In your
application, you
make a call to
getControllerNumber
to determine the controller
driving the input event being
dealt with.
You can use this feature to
make sure your little brother
or sister is playing
as player two.
KRISTAN UCCELLO: You
can now tell Google Play
that your game requires
a game controller.
This could be used to stand out
in the Android TV Play Store.
DAN GALPIN: You add the details
to the application's manifest.
This example indicates
that your game
must be used with a controller.
You can also list all
the supported types
of controls for your game.
If you require either a
multi-touch touchscreen
in gyro, or will work
with a game controller,
then you can use feature groups
to define it in the manifest.
KRISTAN UCCELLO: Now
that you've added support
in the manifest and in game
play, you aren't finished yet.
You need to think about
how the players will
make menu selections, and
provide non-game play input.
DAN GALPIN: One of
the hardest things
that game developers
have to deal
with is focus and selection.
Many games designed
for touch just
don't yet have that concept.
KRISTAN UCCELLO:
One place to start
would be to change the
color of the selected text.
This alone is not
enough, though.
In this example,
you really can't
tell whether the Start Game or
Settings is currently selected.
DAN GALPIN: This
is a bit better.
KRISTAN UCCELLO: It
would be even better
if it were animated.
You know, use motion
to convey context.
DAN GALPIN: Done.
KRISTAN UCCELLO: A lot
of games have buttons,
to connect to social
services, et cetera.
These buttons are often
in non-obvious places
for navigation.
DAN GALPIN: So this is
easier to follow, right?
KRISTAN UCCELLO:
Yeah, but you're
clearly not a UX designer.
BOTH: Remember, hire
a good designer.
DAN GALPIN: One of my
favorite recent games
did a great job with
bringing their game to the TV
and navigating
menus, except that it
was near impossible to actually
purchase anything in the game
without touching the screen.
KRISTAN UCCELLO: It fell down
when it came to purchases?
DAN GALPIN: No one had
tried buying anything
with the controller.
Google Play in-app payment
supports D-pad navigation out
of the box, with a UI
that looks great on TV.
But you have to make sure
the user can get there.
Making your navigation
clear and understandable
is just as important
outside of your main menu.
Make sure that your TV
players aren't missing out.
KRISTAN UCCELLO:
Let's shift gears now,
and discuss another essential
item on the TV development
checklist.
Networking.
DAN GALPIN: So you're
probably thinking
that you know about network
detection on Android.
However, many developers forget
to consider the possibility
of ethernet network connectivity
when building for TV.
KRISTAN UCCELLO:
Android TVs have
wired Ethernet ports to
allow fast networking.
This means that Wi-Fi
may be turned off,
but it's still connected
to the internet.
Mobile developers have
not had to worry much
about fixed, stationary devices.
It's not been common
for developers
to build their
network checking code
to consider connectivity
beyond cellular or Wi-Fi.
DAN GALPIN: The good news
is that it's really easy
to test for network connectivity
without caring about the type,
using this snippet of code.
But if you really want to test
whether wired networking is
active, you can check to
see if the active network is
of type Ethernet.
Understanding the
active hardware
allows your game to
make good decisions
about using bandwidth.
Speaking of
hardware, Android TVs
have graphics hardware exposed
to the power of OpenGL ES.
You can draw out the full
resolution of your TV.
KRISTAN UCCELLO:
With many pixels
comes fillrate responsibility.
Use your pixel power wisely.
DAN GALPIN: Right.
It turns out that
we're not quite
ready to draw graphically
intense 4K scenes
with mobile GPUs.
Yet.
But there's an easy
way to tell Android
that you want to render
at a lower resolution.
If you're using
Java, you can call
SurfaceHolder.setFixedSize,
and that
will tell our composite
engine to scale your smaller
window to the size
of the screen.
KRISTAN UCCELLO: And if
you're like almost every game
developer out there, and not
implementing your graphics
in Java, you can change the size
attribute of the target window.
DAN GALPIN: Hey,
you can still use
GLSurfaceView with
a native renderer.
The contexts are shared.
The key thing is,
you want to make
sure your games look
beautiful on a large screen.
Many of the shortcuts
taken in mobile look
glaring on a large screen.
KRISTAN UCCELLO: Low-res
textures, low poly count
models, geometry rounding
errors, poor bit mappings.
Look, you know what
I'm talking about here.
DAN GALPIN: Amen, brother.
KRISTAN UCCELLO: So with
all this cool rendering,
there's another thing
you have to consider
when developing
for the TV screen.
DAN GALPIN: Other
than epic sizeness?
KRISTAN UCCELLO: Overscan.
It's something that
still inexplicably exists
on modern TVs.
Effectively, this means
that some of your content
may be pushed beyond the
visible edge of the display.
DAN GALPIN: So people
should letterbox content
and have borders?
KRISTAN UCCELLO: No.
Just make sure you
fill the screen.
But keep the
important information
out of the outer
3% of the display.
DAN GALPIN: Like what kind
of important information?
KRISTAN UCCELLO:
HUDs, for example.
It's kind of important
for people to see those.
It can become very annoying
for the user to fiddle
with their TV settings trying
to see the full UI of your game,
only to discover that no matter
what settings they play with,
they still can't
see the whole thing.
Keep the edges of your game
free of critical information.
DAN GALPIN: I wish every
developer knew about overscan,
and didn't have to
know about overscan.
Let's move on to what
developers can do with Google
Play game services.
KRISTAN UCCELLO: Google
Play game services
have been optimized for
Android TV with easy navigation
and a great new look and feel.
DAN GALPIN: You can also utilize
achievement, leader boards,
quests, and more.
KRISTAN UCCELLO: More
being multi-player support.
DAN GALPIN: Yes.
You can utilize
turn-based multi-player
and real-time multi-player
from Play Services.
There's even C++ support
for turn-based multi-player.
KRISTAN UCCELLO: I want to
see some awesome multi-player
experiences with people
playing on their tablets
in the same room so I
can hear them groan.
Second-screen experiences
in the living room
are growing in number.
Game saves could be a great tool
for keeping your users engaged.
Part of extending the
mobile experiences to the TV
means being able
to continue playing
on the biggest,
baddest, most overscan
prone screen in my house.
DAN GALPIN: Cooperative
multi-player
is also worthwhile.
Play games has a great API
for peer-to-peer multi-player
with up to eight players.
It's so much cooler if
some of them can be on TVs.
KRISTAN UCCELLO:
Everything's better on TV.
You know, you can unlock
your RTFM achievement.
DAN GALPIN: Wait, what
achievement was that?
KRISTAN UCCELLO:
Read the full manual.
It's not exactly a manual,
but rather, a website.
We're always trying
to make it better.
DAN GALPIN: And on that note,
help us make TV games better.
In this short talk, we
covered a lot of ground,
but there is always
more to explore.
KRISTAN UCCELLO: In
summary, we looked
at game controllers, and the
importance of navigation,
focus, and selection.
Networking, and why it's
not sufficient to just
look for Wi-Fi.
Graphics rendering on
the TV and the challenges
that overscan can present.
And finally, Google Play
services, and how it can help
bring about the best game
experiences for your users
on TV.
DAN GALPIN: More details about
how to get your game ready
for TV can be found on the new
developer site for Android TV,
including important
manifest changes
to work with our new
lean-back experience.
You can get in touch with us
at +DanGalpin and @dagalpin.
KRISTAN UCCELLO: And
+KristanUccello, or @_krispy_.
BOTH: Now go build something
fun, engaging, and big for us
to play on TV!